The Joe Rogan experience.
Yeah.
I taught fourth grade and now those kids are grown up and that's really cool
because some of them told me it was the best year of their lives.
They come to see me do stand up.
Oh,
that's amazing.
Very cool.
Will you teach and what grade?
Great.
At everything,
but oh,
fourth grade is different than science.
Everything.
I mean,
yeah,
it's different than what you did because you went to some people who had an
interest and a love for something and wanted to explore it what you were doing.
But mine is different.
They had to be there.
So my thing was self doubt,
self esteem.
I figured I can't teach them.
These subjects are going to come and go in their lives,
but teaching them self esteem and some of the most rewarding things where like
uh,
had this one kid who was real shy,
so shy,
he was real tall and he was embarrassed by it and he would stay in the,
in the cloak room,
they'd call it a,
you know,
we're all the coats and you just stay in there.
It won't come out.
I go,
sky,
come,
Sky King because he was a space cadet goes sky,
you got to come out,
they can't stay,
I can't let a kid just sit and,
you know,
and by the end of me just like work in his self esteem and all,
he was in the middle of the class,
just what everybody else waving his hand and his mother came up to me and she
was like really touched by it and told me that I changed his life and,
and you know,
that kind of Shit's cool.
And now I got like a couple of the girls come to see me and she goes,
one of the girls goes,
uh,
ms.dot,
dot,
or why did you let us do so much stuff?
You know,
like I said,
because you were smarter than me.
I said she'd go to me.
I said,
look,
you know,
I always had more knowledge because I was an adult kids.
Lot of you have more brainpower to me.
I know I wasn't smart enough to know that I wasn't.
That's why you ran the class,
you know what I mean?
So you were an easy teacher.
That's what I told them at the beginning of the year.
I said,
look,
I want this to be the most fun year of your life.
Only you can mess it up.
Fucking awesome opportunity.
That must have been.
And I said,
I want to go to the gym.
This is what I was playing basketball.
I said,
I want to go to the gym more than you do.
So we're going to have a party.
Every Friday afternoon we'd have.
We'd have kids that would do break dancing and stuff and really?
Yeah.
That's awesome.
That was great.
Did you ever try to pitch that as a sitcom a no,
but somebody else had an idea for a couple of times would be hilarious.
Sitcom.
It seems like a natural.
Yeah.
You as a,
as a funny teacher because you really did it.
It's legit and if you really stop and think about it,
that would be like for a kid that's like one of the greatest rolls of the dice
and kicked and get for their fourth grade teacher.
I had a girl,
our era for your fourth grade teacher,
she still calls me Mr Herrera.
She was 26 years old or whatever.
He calls me Mr Herrera.
Right.
And I go,
Theresa,
first of all,
you're taller than me.
She's always hot blonde.
I go start with the Mr. you can call me dumb because I just can't call you dumb
net.
Funny.
She's got.
He's got me down as Mr Herrera.
That's good.
That'll keep you from being a dirty bird.
Whoa,
whoa.
Stay away dog.
She's a little girl.
Let her talk call you.
Ms Dot Darwish.
Trying to establish boundaries.
Somebody said,
why do you feel young?
I go because I can come on.
Do you think that becoming more aware or reaching a higher state of
consciousness because of your experiences will actually help you because it'll
abandoned a lot of the distractions that you present yourself almost
unknowingly.
Yeah.
Well it helps me.
It helps me in training and particularly when I'm running now because I used to
listen to like Pantera and patient disorder when I was running and I had worked
myself into like a rage so I wouldn't run into exhaustion.
That was kind of how they're trained and not trained all the way through my
career like that and the last couple of fights,
so sweet stuff.
I listened to a lot more like,
like more like blind binaural beat type of stuff when I'm running so I could get
into more like a meditative stage,
you know,
doing a lot of yoga as well and trying to find the same thing where you just,
you,
you're within yourself and you're not focusing on anything else.
So your body's almost like on autopilot.
Yeah.
That the music that you listened to when you train can have a profound effect on
how you approach your training.
It ready can,
it's so important.
And that's why I've always been so vocal about all this stuff I listen to.
Like I'd,
I'd like training camp playlist,
so I tweet everyday trump songs I was listening to and that kind of thing is
important.
And,
and,
and the other thing as well,
like earlier on in my career,
I would use music to anchor feelings.
So like,
like uh,
when I fought Ludwig I used the song called Ian by Woodkid,
which was the first time I'd switched from Angola belongs to me for like,
you know,
a bunch of fives.
Um,
so like for the 12 weeks of that fight I was training with Frank Mir,
we were going to read it.
It's up to Mount Charleston and now into red rock and like doing hill running
and stuff.
And we had some real tough sessions.
I mean,
you know,
we're ready to put ourselves through for that training camp.
And as soon as I got back in my truck,
after the session,
if I felt like it was a good session that was productive and I felt positive,
I would put that song on and say I would constantly connect those feelings to
that song.
So then when,
when I'm walking out and that song comes on,
immediately I get that feeling again and it's just like,
you know,
just like when you listen to a sermon,
you think of a person like,
oh,
I heard that someone was with that person and you made that connection
immediately,
but you can also train yourself to do it.
So that's why you like allison to Cypress Hill now and it will take me back to
fighting in cage warriors like back in 2006.
Wow.
And I have songs all the way through like that now I don't listen to because it
was like my first two fights.
I came back to Pantera,
drag the waters.
By the time I got to the cage I was so wound up and so angry that I was just run
out of gas immediately.
Know what I mean?
And now whenever I listened to those songs,
I get that feeling of light exhaustion.
Like ugh.
And I look at what's out there.
Some answers make no sense to me and they seem to lead down really unhealthy
path.
So thank you.
But no thanks.
Are there answers?
Make more sense,
or maybe they don't and I come up with my own,
but is it really is boiled down to the Bruce Lee,
you know,
research your own experience,
a reject what is useless,
absorb what is useful and what specific or year on,
you know,
his methodology for how to approach knowledge.
I mean,
he applied it to martial arts by reading is a brilliant way of approach.
Just any kind of knowledge,
whether it is really.
It's about life.
Yeah.
It's hard for people to accept that.
Right?
So it's much easier to follow the pattern that you families followed.
I'm a Lutheran because grandma's Lutheran,
right?
GRANDPA always said that no matter what,
we'll be Lutherans.
Yep.
I remember talking to this girl and uh,
she said that she was going to get a tattoo of a cross and I said,
uh,
I said,
oh,
I go,
you really religious?
She goes,
well,
not really,
but you know what?
I was born Catholic and I figured,
no matter what,
that's the one thing that will be for the rest of my life.
Fuck.
I mean,
and I remember saying and I'm like,
you know,
I didn't know her very well,
so I was like,
okay,
um,
how do you know,
like,
how do you know you won't change your mind about that?
And she's like,
oh my God,
my family would kill me.
And I was like,
oh,
okay.
Well good luck with that.
Good luck with that.
Wow.
Those are examples.
Is that he had at war,
war took on different.
There will be people today's like,
no,
I'm not really nancy,
but you know,
if I don't put the swastika on my grandma would,
her feelings will get really hurt and so it's high.
Don't hate the Jews,
but grandma fucking hates Jews.
And I love grandma.
Yeah,
exactly.
You know,
it's like,
I don't want to make them sad.
What's hilarious is that she was going to get a Catholic tattoo in the first
place because like in the Bible it very specifically says,
so like getting a religious tattoos like,
well you not listening to me,
you know,
only I listened when it's convenient,
but across tattoo is so sexy.
It makes me look spiritual and it thins out my back.
That's the fault of the people get pissed when you are.
You could eat at all and he's like,
what do you mean create your own?
It's not.
There are some absolute truths that fall from heaven.
They stop those people that are making up their own sheet anyway.
I mean,
when people say a full time thing is bullshit.
They are making up their own thing because they.
We'll add some parts of that they don't like.
They will focus on the parts daylight and pretend that it's the one and only
interpretation and say if you're going to do that,
might as well be honest and just peek from any source.
If you're going to be continuous.